When you're a hulk trouble's
gonna find you this thursday weird
unexpected trouble let's do this seahawk culture
but it's not where you think remember whose show
this actually is she-hulk is streaming on disney
plus this thursday. Welcome back everyone it's
charlie this will be my marvel she-hulk episode
3 trailer video there were a whole bunch
of teasers i will explain what's going on
with that hulk scene where he's leaving planet
going back to sakaar and what's going on with
wong in abomination because there were a lot of
questions about what happened with their fight
in the shangshi movie and the end of the episode
so if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the episodes i'll be doing
videos for all the she-hulk episodes just like
all the other marvel disney plus series we're
doing a giveaway for disney plus memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and post all your theories in the comments below
careful for spoilers for episode 2 if you haven't
seen it yet but during episode 2 she was hired by
glk and h given the abomination case in order to
win him parole in court so he could get out of
prison then everybody found out about him leaving
prison early with wong to fight in the shangshi
movie in that underground fight ring in macau
treating it as if it were a legit prison break
even though he's back in his cell and bruce
banner revealed that he left earth with the
same cigar spaceship to go back to cigar without
saying exactly why only saying that he'd be busy
for a while like it was gonna take a good long
while i'll start with the abomination stuff
because in the trailer that's the most obvious
stuff like we see him in prison in his abomination
form like he does go back to abomination form
while they're continuing to work on his case
and then wang also shows up inside his cell with
a bunch of other people to explain the connection
why they were fighting in the shangshi movie
in the first place what that was all about
we all make the jokes about how wong was doing it
to earn sandwich money just because he complained
he was so broke all the time even though now he
is source for supreme apparently like the avengers
the sorcerer's supreme also does not get paid
but also wong is going to help set up his future
arc in the series with the other lawsuit that
she helps him with in later episodes that seems
like a completely separate thing wong seems like
he's in a couple episodes just based on how much
plot they cover for his character because of how
short each episode is it doesn't seem like they
cover that much plot so they just dedicate it to
like one big thing per episode you have all that
scene of wong fighting with her inside the magic
club also fighting in this other trial with this
girl here that seems like a completely separate
thing from the abomination case we also have all
the other abomination scenes that are having
this special support group that he's leading
outside the prison there's a whole bunch of stuff
going on during that it actually seems like it's
either happening at the end of this episode
or in a completely different episode either
way it seems like she's successful in winning in
parole and that's why he's in the outside world
makes sense because her boss basically told her
she wouldn't have a job anymore if she didn't
successfully get him out of prison in the comics
her law firm takes a lot of super villain cases
helping them get out of trouble for doing really
bad stuff so i do like the idea that glk and h the
law firm just in general is working for val as she
clears the legal red tape for a lot of these super
villains and more hardcore anti-heroes so that
she can put together the thunderbolts and the
law firm is just using she-hulk as a front to do
that leg work for them like we won't tell you why
we want you to get abomination out of prison he's
paying us but it's also because this other person
over here is paying us to help get them out of
prison so that she can put together this huge team
and it sounds like they're going to play their
version of the thunderbolts in less of a suicide
squad kind of way like they're not going to do it
as a copy of suicide squad they'll do it more of a
dark avengers way which is why val would secretly
be using she-hulk to clear a lot of this legal red
tape without her learning about it in the vibe of
the mcu thunderbolts will be more like the dark
avengers where they're all free and clear of all
the charges against them or their pardon for all
their crimes so that val can pretend in public
that they're like the real superheroes everybody
should worship that's kind of what norman osborne
did in the comics with dark avengers like he put
them forth as the people that everyone should
worship like these are all superheroes but
it was all secretly anti-heroes and super
villains that did really really bad stuff
and in the mcu they'll play it more like the boys
tv show does with homelander in the seven that's
actually a really good comparison especially
what happened during the boys season three
where they do all the super messed up stuff and
val is kind of like the stan edgar of the group
just making everybody in the public believe that
they're actually superheroes sort of the same way
in the boy season 3 where things get to the point
at the end of the series where homelander realizes
that he can kill people in broad daylight in
a crowd of people and they still worship him
for it it'll be like that vibe with val and
the thunderbolts when they show up in the mcu
assuming they don't recast thunderbolt ross or do
like a multiverse thing where sam elliott comes
back as the thunderbolt ross in the mcu because
william hurt passed away that would also mean them
doing a different iteration of red hulk but i only
think we're going to get teasers for the actual
mcu thunderbolts team until we get to like captain
america for new world order it's not that far off
and they'll have some kind of legit thunderbolts
post-credit scene where they tease the actual team
and then they show up for real and go on their
first real big mission during the thunderbolts
movie and leading up to that we'll just get
more val cameo scenes where it seems like
she's recruiting the team pulling strings from
behind the scenes to explain what's going on
with the shangshi abomination scene the timeline
with the she-hulk broadcast people are confused
because of what was going on with banner's
arm like when is it broken when is it fixed
when does this take place the explanation that
the she-hulk writers gave is actually a little bit
more confusing than the explanation that i came
up with after watching the series just based on
the clues that they were giving us the she-hulk
writers were trying to say that hulk's arm is only
fixed because of she-hulk's blood when he's in
the smart hulk form like if he went back to banner
form the she-hulk writers are saying that his arm
would be broken again but in general the events of
she-hulk episode 2 are meant to take place after
the shangshi post-credits scene i think so i think
it makes more sense to just say that her origin
story like the car crash all that stuff happened
right after the shangshi post credit scene and
that's why his arm was still broken during the
shangshi post credit scene but like i said when
wong shows up in episode 3 that'll provide a lot
more context and explain that a lot more and for
those of you asking about the book of ashanti here
in the timeline with doctor strange multiverse of
madness the scene is meant to take place before
the events of doctor strange too the reason why
he knows about the book in this scene though
is because as he explains in the events of the
movie when they're having that pizza with doctor
strange and american chavez because he's sorcerer
supreme he has knowledge of all these secret books
of magic that doctor strange doesn't know about so
that's why during the movie he already knows about
it but doctor strange does not which is why he
can make the joke about it here before the events
of that movie with she-hulk as for hulk leaving
the planet to go back to sakaar on that spaceship
if you look around the spaceship you can see
he's got a whole desk full of his research with
the monitor displaying similar readings that he
was analyzing in his underground lab when he was
going over their blood the writers also answered
a lot of our theories that it was meant to be set
up for a marvel movie like they'll pay it off
in the movies not on the she-hulk series so i
think if they reference this moment again like
what's actually going on with the hook it'll be
like another real quick teaser with a couple more
clues but outside of that i think the only other
thing that hulk does on the series is just help
her get her comic book suit that he's made from
similar materials from his student avengers
end game like he'll give her the full outfit
she's even got special shoes she's wearing here
and though just explained that he'd been making
it this whole time before he left and he sent
it to her before he left and it just takes a
couple more episodes for her to get it because you
see her wearing it when she's with daredevil and
that's not going to happen for a couple episodes
i think mark ruffalo was also talking about doing
a world war hulk movie or a planet hulk movie
and doing the worldbreaker version of hook to
make a she-hulk reference doing a more savage
version of hulk again the closest they've ever
gotten to worldbreaker hook would be in avengers
end game when he went a little bit nuts but that
wasn't worldbreaker hulk worldbreaker hulk
is way more powerful way more out of control
the difference with his character too is that
he still has the mind of banner and that's
the dangerous part it's a little bit easier to
defeat the mindless version of hulk because he's
more vulnerable to mental attacks from people like
professor x for instance or telepaths worldbreaker
hulk is like the smart version of hulk just super
super mad so he's a much more dangerous fighter
because he has his genius level intellect it's
almost like the maestro version of the hulk only
the maestro is just like this evil future version
like he's legit evil worldbreaker hulk is just
really really pissed off he was also talking about
timothy chalamet becoming a version of the hulk in
the future and now because of all the teasers in
episode 1 and episode 2 it sounds like they might
be doing a version of that planet hulk storyline
that they didn't do in thor ragnarok because they
only did part of his storyline from that and it
might be a path to them doing skaar son of hulk so
it would be funny if timothy chalamet actually did
show up in the mcu as skaar i don't think that's
going to happen like obviously this is just a meme
him just pretending to be hulk being funny but if
we're going to get worldbreaker hulk in the movies
there has to be a reason why he loses control but
still has the genius level intellect of banner
and i think doing something to his son or doing
something to she-hulk would accomplish that if
they don't actually do a legit planet hulk or
world war hulk movie they could still do that same
arc during captain america 4 in the thunderbolts
movie like the thunderbolts debuted for the
first time in the hulk comics just like wolverine
debuted in the whole comics they could actually
make it so that the thunderbolts first mission
is to take down the hulk and it becomes more of a
captain america civil war situation with hulk at
the center of everything or she-hulk at the center
of everything i also think that val is trying
to get the powers of the hulk the same way that
thunderbolt ross was just using different methods
and that's why they had him in episode one making
such a big deal about burning all of her blood
samples so i think that'll come back around too
like someone will also try to get her blood and
use it to replicate the powers of the hulk as well
but post all your theories in the comments below
like what are all these teasers for when are they
going to pay off all this hulk stuff in sakaar my
full she-hulk episode 3 video will post next week
after it releases my house of the dragon episode
2 video is also going to post on sunday there's a
bunch of big stuff happening we'll also get lord
of the rings episode soon i'll be doing videos
for that and star wars and or episodes after that
so there'll be like four or five really big shows
on at the same time that i'll be doing videos for
congratulations sparrow you're the giveaway winner
for my last big marvel video please email me on
the about page of my channel so i can get your
contact details everyone click here for my full
she-hulk episode 2 video in easter eggs and click
here for my house of the dragon episode 2 trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!